in this video I wanted to do a very
brief introduction to glycolysis which
is a pathway that we're going to be
talking about more in future videos so
what is glycolysis glycolysis literally
comes from glyco which you know implies
the sugar and lysis which means to break
up so basically glycolysis means
splitting sugar which sugar in
particular are we splitting you probably
already know this the answer is glucose
which is a six carbon molecule so is
this process process aerobic or
anaerobic what we'll find out is that
this process well first of all what is
Arabic Arabic means requires oxygen
anaerobic means does not require oxygen
so glycolysis is actually an anaerobic
process because no oxygen is required
for glycolysis to occur okay how many
steps is glycolysis there are actually
10 enzyme catalyzed steps to glycolysis
and the way I kind of think about it is
there's there are two phases one being
the the investment phase the second
being the payoff phase so glycolysis is
first five reactions will be considered
the investment phase in which we invest
to ATP right so invent we normally when
you invest anything right if you invest
money in a particular company or idea or
something you expect some sort of return
right and you expect them and hope the
return is larger so in the payoff phase
which is just the second five reactions
of glycolysis we actually make a total
of four ATP so if you think about that
four minus two we actually net two ATP
so part of the reason I call it part of
the purpose of glycolysis two is to
create ATP but in just a moment I'll
mention a few other things that like
pollicis is important for we have to be
a keep in mind we're in the cell does
glycolysis occur by collossus occurs in
the cytosol right over the cytoplasm so
it does not occur in a membrane-bound
organelle other pathways it's important
to keep in mind where these pathways
actually occur and I'll get to that
later but bear in mind that glycolysis
occurs in the side of
now um one thing I want to mention
before I go on about how this is whether
this is an oxidation of a reductive
pathway we're taking this glucose and
we're actually splitting it up and I
mentioned just a moment ago that glucose
is a six carbon molecule so in one in
one round of glycolysis we take one
glucose molecule which is a six carbon
molecule and we turned it into two three
carbon molecules called pyruvate these
are three carbon molecules okay so
knowing this is this an oxidative or
reductive pathway well or as n-digit
anabolic or catabolic process well if
you watch the last video you probably
remember that anabolism is the building
of macromolecules or building a
molecules and catabolic means the
breaking down of molecules so in this
case we're taking glucose and we're
making it into two pyruvate two smaller
components so this will definitely be a
catabolic pathways because we're
breaking something down now if you
recall I mentioned Arco right and Arco
is just a short acronym to help you
remember that an anabolic process is
reductive and a catabolic process is
oxidative so this this process is an
oxidative pathway it's an oxidative
catabolic process okay and it's
catabolic because we're taking glucose
and we're breaking it down into a
simpler component now if we start off
with one glucose molecule in glycolysis
and that got a white out one glucose
molecule goes all the way through what
do we net in terms of products so what
are the products of glycolysis given one
glucose molecule well one of our
products is of course is that we get two
pyruvates
excuse me we get two pyruvates okay and
we net two ATP in addition we also
create two NADH ha's okay so what's the
point of all these different things the
pyruvate has a different possible fates
let me note that here the depending on
whether or not there's oxygen available
which I'll get
to later there are many different fates
possible not fat fates possible for
pyruvate it can go onto the TCA cycle or
it can be fermented which again we'll
talk about later to ATP which of course
can be used for energy and to nadh --is
which are supposed to go to the electron
transport chain the electron transport
chain okay to be re oxidized to generate
energy again we'll talk more about that
later but hopefully that was a good
little introduction as far as what
glycolysis is all about thanks for
watching